well I was talking about those videos of
you guys taping yourselves how many of
those do you do for for these hyper
movies so shooting references yeah I
tend to do it on a shop pro shop basis
usually the acting performances I'll do
reference and we shoot each other's
references I know you do yours right
what's the weirdest reference tape
you've done climbing over a cliff and I
tried to climb over a half wall in our
house like as if I was a dinosaur no I
had half wall but Arlo has no arms I
mean yeah he has no hands so I was just
trying to use my head to do it and it
was like don't show this to anybody
deletes I don't I or Kyle all of it
because you know you do bus stuff but
you also do teaching things and they're
good teachable moments to show your
production of your your work what do you
take away from these sort of reference
tapes how does that influence the
animation process each shot is different
so personally when I look at the
reference I'm trying to gather ideas but
I'm also trying to gather attitudes and
feelings that I they tried to do it's
kind of like acting it's the same thing
we're just trying to perform the
character and see what naturally comes
so that we can infuse that into the
character because that's probably the
hardest thing we do you know we work on
a shot for weeks and you want to make it
feel like it's just natural and it
happened you know really quick sure and
so but you have to feel that moment
throughout who's gonna what is the
typical day like for an animator at
Pixar what is that sort of process a
typical day um actually animating it we
have our reviews with our director we
show our work
where we're at with our shot we get our
notes back to our desk and try to find a
way to implement all those notes how
much is a shot change from from the
initial design to sort of it depends it
depends on how whether you hit out of
the park spend two weeks really
meticulously working on something and
then it's just not the right the right
feeling or the right emotion or the
wrong action and that happens often and
then sometimes it's just hit it's like
okay it's great and then you're just
cleaning it up from there yeah you know
the sequence that we did together with
Helen and Bob you know we showed that
for the first time to Brad and and I
think I got one of my biggest
compliments I ever gotten in in my
career where he was like just passed me
the popcorn I'm ready to watch this
movie and which is like okay he like he
liked everything he was he was really
happy he didn't really have it was very
little notes on it so it was very we got
very lucky in that yeah
but it's hard because the animator side
of you is like there's no way it could
be right you're always you're always
learning every shot you learn in
constantly and so and Brad is this
amazing teacher so he's one of those
things that he can you want to get ideas
you want to get his notes you feel like
you'll grow as an artist so when you
don't get notes you're kind of like sure
okay what changed the most from the
initial design to sort of finished
product on this movie I can tell you I
think being a second it already had it
it's you know beginnings you know he
already had the first film to to bounce
off so the the world of the design and
everything the mid-century modern feel
was already established on the first
film so I think you know we they just
grew and you know just based on that and
I think just evolving the characters was
the biggest thing Jack Jack and Helen
were the main points of this film so you
know we wanted to evolve their
characters further along and I think you
know Jack Jack especially he was I think
it's this scene stealer you know he
totally is amazing but he has all these
powers and it it was great and so I
think what I've heard from fans
I want more Jack Jack and they love that
enough right so they love that moment so
they're gonna get that helpful to have
you know pre-existing Incredibles for
your head for animation is it easier
working that way with this sort of
pre-existing material yes because you
don't have to figure out who the
characters are you've got the design
kind of figured out the appeal what
their face should look like and who they
are and said this it's a nice
jumping-off point where you don't have
to you've got that much of the work
finished for you and now you can just
take it further which is my yeah you're
just evolving the characters and it's
great I neither one of us worked on the
first one and it was one of my my
favorite films you know as I was
animating at other Studios but it was
one of those things Wow I can't believe
I actually get to work on their
Incredibles film with Brad Bird and so
it but it's great to look back at that
as you're working because you want to
make them feel like the same character
you